Évelyne Thomas nous rejoint l'année
prochaine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
très très heureux de les accueillir je
vous dis franchement très heureux voilà
donc Evelyne je l'aime depuis des années
sachez qu'on puisse Evelyne elle m'a
toujours aidé quand j'étais au fond du
trou Evelyne était là pour moi j'allais
la voir au bureau et c'est vrai que je
restais sur le canapé
sur le canapé tranquille et le passé ça
va Cyril tout va bien ouais moi je vais
faire sourire mon choix c'est ton choix
de rester là
ecoute voilà c'est vrai que ça fait
longtemps aussi que Alex je l'ai je l'ai
en tête et ça y est il nous rejoint et
je suis très heureux aussi parce que
c'est quelqu'un que j'aime autant dans
la vie que à l'antenne et je pense qu'il
va nous apporter beaucoup voilà donc
j'espère que c'est ce qu'on va au
nouveau petit camarades et il y a encore
d'autres nouveaux petits camarades qui
vont arriver
sachez-le voilà ça va arriver mais vous
inquiétez pas tout le monde aura du
travail comme je l'ai dit il y aura des
arrivées et
et comme ça c'est comme ça Hugo tu as
été confirmé toi pour l'année prochaine
je crois bien moi j'ai mon stylo n'a pas
encore fait la signature mais en tout
cas j'ai oui dire que c'est confiance
donc merci merci
[Applaudissements]
tu es heureux tu es heureux merci de me
faire confiance
moi aussi je tiens à vous dire je suis
très content que vous m'ayez confirmé
[Applaudissements]
il y a beaucoup de gens qui voudraient
être à ma place je sais très bien qu'il
y a beaucoup de gens qui voudraient être
à ma place
et tu es excellent et voilà je travaille
pour eux j'ai été confirmé pour
l'émission de demain bravo
[Applaudissements]
donc on est obligé de faire le tri et
c'est vrai que de grands noms va nous
rejoindre et vous allez voir c'est pas
encore fini je vous le dis aussi il y
aura une chronique l'année prochaine
autour d'une chronique très drôle en
train de travailler depuis on est en
train de travailler depuis un an donc
je pense qu'on sera prêt
voilà on sera normalement presque prêts
en fait on est on est triste qui reste
trois émissions mais on est on est
content dans des coups de l'année
prochaine et sachez les chéris qu'il y
aura un nouveau décor
comme on dit j'ai mis la main à la poche
et là il y a comme une vague de
fraîcheur comme ça et là on repart dans
le drame
malheureusement oui mais bon on va
pouvoir l'amortir
et un nouvel animateur on garde les
mains
[Applaudissements]
de vieux de plus en plus mais c'est
sympa quand même non et je voudrais dire
Jean-Michel était confirmé
parce que comment ça se passe c'est
Lionel Stan le directeur général
[Rires]
il est magnifique
quand j'arrive au bureau c'est-à-dire
une fois une fois par mois donc j'arrive
et il fait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je l'adore ah c'est le meilleur c'est le
meilleur tout le monde veut me le piquer
mais il reste lui aussi voilà il va il
va grandir
les chéris sachez donc voilà que tout va
bien donc voilà je vous dis on est on
est pressé aussi d'être l'année
prochaine on est on est pressé aussi
voilà on est auprès de faire les
missions parce qu'on kiffe tous les
soirs et vraiment on a kiffé cette année